so i'm gonna bury you right here but
you'll be dead before stevie pulls your
teeth accurate he says all right take
his teeth out back in those days they
didn't have dna they would identify
bodies by dental records my name is mark
silverman and i was involved in
organized crime with the italians and uh
the irish today we're going to be
looking at some irish mob movie scenes
and we're going to judge how real they
are
what do you get your period
[Music]
one thing about bars too is you always
know who's coming in and out so you have
a good idea if the stranger's in there
or if there's something that doesn't
look right
you can really find out if somebody's
there to infiltrate the bar or cause
trouble
are you still a cop no
no
that's a great scene i i i could tell
you one thing and
it struck me right away when i saw the
movie for the first time the state
police
are not going to try to put one of their
own inside of a crew especially a
dangerous crew
that's why they recruit informants or
top echelon informants because
the informants can walk the walk and
talk the talk and
i
have never really seen
an undercover police officer inside of a
crew
a lot of people used to say well you
know i know that guy's a cop because of
his shoes i would say
you don't think that they
know what shoes to wear and what not to
wear you know yeah always always looking
over your shoulder for that yeah you
know i saw her cop when i came in here
when i was pulling into the parking lot
i didn't miss that but these days i
don't have to worry about it guys on the
street like me that are looking at us
saying wow that's pretty good
[Music]
school's up
thank you frank
police corruption back in
the 80s and the 90s was rampant whitey
bulger
certainly wasn't the only guy
that had the inside track with some of
the departments whether they be local or
state or federal
other guys i mean you're not going to
survive on the street if you don't have
friends within law enforcement and back
then
you know police didn't really make as
much money as they did today and they
were much more easily corrupted we moved
on to the 2000s i think that
they got a little more
stringent you know they wanted to
eradicate organized crime they wanted to
just put that final nail in the coffin
which they claimed to have done several
times we're not even supposed to be
doing this this close to worcester
this side it wasn't
so says him says costello
this is very accurate so they're
obviously nervous it's all about
territory if you're dealing drugs doing
any type of business in somebody else's
territory you are absolutely open to
discipline however that discipline is
carried out it depends on the severity
of the action like if you look at
like medford you know somerville
you know winter hill south boston
you know who's who and you know we
should be doing things and where you
shouldn't because if you don't someone
will get your attention one way or
another and you probably won't like it
but
that's what happens you know he's got
some real good scenes in there and
good storyline so yeah i'd say it's
pretty accurate i'll give it a i'll give
it a seven
listen uh
just wanted to stop by and tell you
myself
is that the zip code for south boston uh
no it's child's top everybody has the
the fighting irish guy usually like on
their on their calf you know what i mean
and
you know it's it's not really like a
requirement or anything it's just that
they're proud i mean they should be
there they're always going to honor and
respect it where they come from i think
my guys can handle it without me
really i wouldn't hire them without you
and i wouldn't hire you without them
you're a unit
everybody in the crew has a role part of
his crew is the bank robbery crew he's
not going to put your footbed on it you
know he's not going to do that he's not
going to hire one without the other
they're going to do it together they do
it right they do it well they keep the
money flowing the irish mafia i mean
they're they're loosely knit
crews you know that don't necessarily
follow the uh
the pyramid of the structure of power
that the italians have you have your
bookies you have your drug dealers you
have your hijackers everybody has a role
but the earner the guy that fill in the
pockets
of the higher-ups is the most important
guy in that crew
just out of respect smooth things over
let's take this far all right
not gonna cut us
you're gonna do what i ask
yeah he doesn't want his money you know
he's much more valuable to him
continuing to make money you know your
earners
you put you will do anything to keep
them earning for you because they're
hard to find believe me when i tell you
you know there's a lot of knuckleheads
out there that
you put them on the street you know they
last about a week it's like in reality
too it's the old-timers
that really
have the juice i always respected the
old timers more than anything because
these guys have more wisdom in their
pinky finger than the guys the young
that's a nine
i think that's probably why i haven't
seen this movie
because
that seems kind of crazy
kind of elaborate to do a hit i didn't
know that mob hitmen were acrobats and
stuntmen it just seems like a lot of
unnecessary work to get your message
across their feet may swiftly carry out
that command so we shall flow a river
forth to thee and teeming with souls
shall it ever be i don't know a lot of
irish mobsters that they talk like that
it's like a little bit of what the
brogue you know most of them are born
here you know they don't come over from
dublin or
anything like that
maybe i met one or two i'm not quite
sure it was a long time ago with that
but
i'm giving it a 2.
right that's enough
man just [ __ ] like that i was one of
hell
so a lot of people believe that whitey
bulger was part of the winter hill gang
he was at the beginning i don't think i
would ever say he was the leader of the
winter hill gang he was the leader of
the bulger group or whatever you want to
call it he was running with the gangs in
south boston there was a power struggle
and they wanted to iron out those
problems and
the ultimate result of it was hey let's
combine it you know why don't we make
ourselves strong why don't we blend
salty and went the hill and make it all
one crew and that's what they did
but in 1978 all of a sudden this huge
indictment comes down against the entire
winnihill gang i mean
guys like whitey stevie
howie
john madorano the who's who of the irish
mafia in 1978 and it's funny because
as
it was taking its course you know these
guys either went on the limb or some of
them went to jail or were awaiting trial
all of a sudden
you hear the word
unindicted co-conspirators when it came
to steve flemmi
and whitey bulger so an unindicted
co-conspirator kind of raised a lot of
antennas and again
that's where people fail to realize is
that
once he eliminates winter hill
he becomes the bulger group i told him
everything the ira got hill the whole
bit but you'll be dead before stephen
pulls your teeth
accurate
he says to stevie flummy he says all
right take his teeth out
you know back in those days they didn't
have dna
you know so
they would identify bodies by dental
records i think in the movie too they
they referred to um
a dumping ground
where they
dumped a lot of bodies
quite a few
i remember when the state police were
digging it up
it was bad
really bad i thought that was great
everything down from you know to the
walk to the eyes you know why he had
these eyes that were
like grayish blue with like no emotion
behind them and
i think you'll see a lot of times in
this movie when they show the eyes like
they'll focus specifically on the eyes
they looked pretty good i'm giving this
one an eight i thought this one was
gritty
it was raw it was pretty
accurate ever since you come in the
restaurant you can't stop yakking it's
smoochy dish smoochy that guy always
wore the scally cap and i was kind of a
tracksuit type of guy yeah a lot of a
lot of irish guys wear them it's not a
requirement you know
and i just like them you're a good boy
mopes don't think we don't remember
favors you're welcome at our place
anytime come on boys
the irish will work with anybody that's
making money that's willing to work with
them i mean there was like a big ethnic
stew of
of
of people you know you didn't have to be
a certain you know religion or
like i said ethnicity there was italians
there was polish there was jewish if you
have talent
you can earn
they don't really care what your last
name is or what your religion is you
know it's about money you can make the
money
you know you can be as
you know you can be an atheist i don't
know maybe a six five right around there
what the hell transferring them the
reich's let's go sorry baby if a guy
goes to jail
you know i mean he's risking that he's
risking losing his family we gotta have
um
money you know our envelope you're
welcome
there was less in it than what we were
expecting and so
guys go to jail 10 12 14 years and they
come up with nothing
and what they come out to is most times
their friends have betrayed them and
taken over the businesses that they had
and
never took care of never went to their
wife and said hey you know there's a
little package you know i mean i think
you should take care of them they're
supposed to
but
don't expect it you know you see what
this whole organized crime thing has
become
disloyalty
no honor amongst thieves anymore all
everybody wants to do
is look out for a number one i left
organized crime because i saw the
direction that it was going i saw guys
that lost their families and were
betrayed by their best friends and it
was just too much and i realized that
i made the wrong decisions in my life
how much were you expecting from me
payments are down
the collection sit down who's not paying
collections are always down you know i
mean
most mob guys
are great actors and and their best
performances are when they're crying
foremost we know you did a score
for 80 000 but you have no money you
know you can't even buy a cup of coffee
come on in that scene where she was
asking for the money you know he's got
the money believe me but uh not giving
it to her you know something maybe about
a five yeah here's a few bucks for you
lucky you're getting that i don't sit
down here get over there now come on sit
down
man i'm [ __ ] with you
hey can you get it get him a
i think it's a great scene i really do
i mean they're just hanging out having a
few beers it seemed like there were
other patrons in the place you know if
you're in a mob bar or a social club or
whatever sometimes they'll just come
over to the table and just whisper
something in your ear or just say
you know
come to the back room in 10 minutes i
gotta talk to you you two aren't there
on your own and we don't see a dime
we've been running around like a couple
of [ __ ] boys for you for 15 years and
what do we have to show for it nothing i
like the way that the
boss let them know that you know look
you guys got to kick up and these guys
are saying they're standing on their
ground saying look
we do the scores man you know i got kids
to feed you know what are we aaron boys
and
obviously if they've been doing it 15
years they're far from aaron boys never
tell how many how much money you made on
a score because believe me people will
chase you down like i remember i
specifically did one that was really
really big and it was a windfall
and i had people coming from every
direction as soon as someone hears you
did a big score in town they got their
hand out most guys live score to score
you know if you hit a score you know
you're going to take a little time off
you know you got it you get the money
we're not setting up iras we're not
diversifying our stock portfolios we're
not thinking about we're thinking about
today
we're thinking about spending that money
because we know that once we run out
let's go into another one you know it's
not a long-term
business that uh
you know you can retire from you know
that's why you see guys out there that
are 75 80 years old that are still
hustling i'm gonna go probably eight and
a half i really like this thanks for
watching and if you enjoyed the video
click the link above